big fan of his work from not only behind
the mic from the days when he was
coaching my favorite basketball team
Jeff Van Gundy back here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Jeff
Goodrich you know you shouldn't feel so
bad about the Yankees was up losing to a
superior team in the Astros you guys
gave it a good shot so you know what you
don't feel good about the year you had
no I mean no I know I feel that way you
know 100 win season and and I just love
watching some of these guys make
something of themselves whether they was
expected of them or not so you are right
Jeff I do and my worst day as a as a
sports fan yes I remember my birthday in
1973
UCLA's 88 game winning streak came to a
halt at Notre Dame they went on an 11 o
run I think at the end to beat Bill
Walton that was like the worst why was
that so bad for you we s you're just I
was such a UCLA fan and it was on tape
delay so they were up like eight or nine
ten with like three to go without a shot
clock you sillies never losing this game
and I knew they lost before but I didn't
believe it when I when I was watching it
on replay I thought I had misheard it
and then it ruined my birthday so it was
like my 12th birthday you know it was a
bad day well what did you love about
UCLA so much Jeff like what spoke to you
about that we won every game that's what
I jumped on the bandwagon in Calvin
Northern California at the time growing
up I jumped on the bandwagon with UCLA
so that's it was very simple and you
only member back then there was no TV
except on like local teams so that's the
only games we got was UCLA it was Dick
Enberg calling the game of course it was
I mean it was amazing here in Southern
California Dick Enberg and and an
obviously Vince Scully and you know just
some of the legendary voices you know
calling games here in Southern
California did you ever come across with
John paths with John Wooden Jeff Jeremy
no you know I was coaching I never met
him but I was coaching the Knicks in the
playoffs and Walton was doing one of our
games
and somehow it came up I was a UCLA fan
and so he called and this was post Ewing
so we were playing Sprewell in Houston
where our best players right and so we
were posting them up a lot so anyway
Bill Walton this was right before the
game like an hour and a half before the
game calls coach wooden up I get on the
phone with them I'm like fawning about
like you know him
and he goes you know what I'd rather see
though I'd rather see Houston and
Sprewell face the basket more instead of
play with their back to the basket I win
and I said hey guys you know like coach
wouldn't say like you guys to play with
your so face up a little bit more
tonight so we can win this game yes so
that was my only time ever got a chance
to talk to him Wow geez so did you win
the game that night did they face up
more based on I have no idea so it's
like an oo ya ah dasa T of Walton to
call up John Wooden and to think that
John Wooden was actually watching our
game that's not as uh that is um yeah
humbling Jeff Jeff Van Gundy here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so most wide open
season that you've seen in the NBA since
when would you say going into this
campaign that starts tomorrow Jeff well
I think you know obviously pre pre
Warriors once they had it rolling but
even back then there's always been
favorites I just don't see like I don't
have a good feel on who I would say the
favorite would be I know everybody's
saying you know the Los Angeles teams
and maybe you feel like it's Milwaukee
because most likely they'll be the top
seed or even you can make a case for
Philadelphia but I'm really interested
I'm really interested in who makes the
playoffs because I think particularly in
the Western Conference injury can really
determine whether you make it or don't
what seed you get home court advantage
or not so I'm really I'm interested to
see how it plays out I'm also interested
to see which teams try to have a really
good regular season or which teams are
trying to pace their players
throughout the regular season your are
you going load management on me there
Jeff is that what that was right there
yeah I just don't like it because I just
hate that term it's we've tried to make
load management seem like there's some
science behind it there's not it's all
guessing if there was science and we
could prevent injuries and we would see
we wouldn't see all the injuries we see
in sports so yeah I don't like to give
load management any credence at all Jeff
Van Gundy here on the Rich Eisen show
and the Lakers here in Los Angeles
obviously have all the eyes on them for
all the obvious reasons how is it going
to work however is there a concern for
you in the Vogel Jason Kidd scenario
that has been put together by the front
office where Vogel's the head coach and
kid is the assistant that a lot of
people assume is the choice of LeBron
and Vogel's the choice of say Phil
Jackson in the year of the front office
what do you say to that Jeff Van Gundy
well I don't know what their dynamic is
because I don't know what you know Jason
Kidd's thinking but I think Jason Kidd
is a very good it was a very good head
coach at multiple spots he's smart
I thought his team's played tough but
anybody under estimating Frank Vogel and
his skill with people number one and
coaching acumen number two they would be
under estimating him greatly this was a
guy at Indiana who did a magnificent job
and the only thing that stopped them
from getting to the finals was they kept
running into LeBron James in Miami then
he went to Orlando and they did they
were trying to rebuild so they lost a
lot but I thought it was an inspired
choice to pick him with the Lakers I
think he's going to work well with their
roster I have no worries about their
roster Frank Vogel at all so and no
worries about any dynamic that might be
playing out on the bench anyway I'd be
very surprised because I think okay as a
former head coach Jason Kidd understands
to have success you have to play your
role and as an assistant coach
that means you have to at times make
suggestions that you think strongly
about that will not get adapted their
head coach doesn't agree and I think he
probably went through that with his own
assistant coaches both in Brooklyn and
Milwaukee I think he understands his
role in his place I'd be surprised if
there's any problems Jeff Van Gundy here
on the Rich Eisen show and what do you
think's going through Steve Kerr's mind
as he gets started for this season I
think probably in some ways Steve is
really excited about the year it's
different it's the dynamics different
the expectations are different I'm sure
he's excited about teaching so many
young guys being on the practice floor
more I think Curry's going to have an
MVP season but I think you know when
when all you've done is win and win big
it's going to be obviously more of a
struggle to win more of a struggle to
qualify for the playoffs and you know
the Western Conference is hard it's
going to be difficult it's going to be a
challenge but I think Steve is a
terrific terrific coach I got to work
with him in the World Cup this summer I
saw firsthand how good he was so I have
no doubt that they'll play very very
well and Curry's could have an MVP
season and yet it could still be a
struggle to make the playoffs or advance
in the playoffs and in terms of just
teams that have put together rosters to
try and win a championship
Houston obviously we saw what the Lakers
and Clippers have done the Sixers a lot
of people like what they have done which
do you think is the biggest coaching
challenge to get together and get
everybody on the same page in time to
make a push what's the biggest challenge
do you think for a coach that has this
now on their plate I think Philadelphia
is going to be a challenge I think Brett
Brown all he's had there is huge
challenges he's got a point guard who's
not a range shooter in Simmons they're a
huge team their depth has been
diminished they don't have a lot of
shooting Horford is going to play at the
power floor
but as truly as NBA center the health
issues of in beed so I think there's so
many questions such roster turnover not
sure necessarily that the roster fits
great together but they are certainly
talented I think that is the team that
I'm most interested in in watching
throughout the season tell me about this
goal Asano training center opening at
Nazareth College Jeff I know you're very
involved with the Special Olympics New
York and and in this particular facility
what's going on up there back on my own
well opened up Tom Golisano and his
foundation were the lead donor to this
Golisano training center at Nazareth
College which is my where I went and
graduated from college and it's a
spectacular Fieldhouse that's going to
both benefit the student-athletes at
Nazareth College but more importantly
rich the Special Olympic athletes our
students here at Nazareth in the Health
and Human Services major are going to be
working directly with the Special
Olympic athletes it's a truly
spectacular building but more so it's a
spectacular opportunity for the athletes
both our student-athletes at Nazareth
and the Special Olympic athletes to get
the training they so richly deserve and
you know this is a very inclusive and
cooperative venture between the Golisano
foundation Nazareth College and Special
Olympics of New York and we couldn't be
more proud to be here for the opening of
the building today and see the
possibilities that can happen and I
would I would you know all your
listeners if they want to see what great
things are happening with Special
Olympics just go to join the revolution
org that's join the revolution dot org
congratulations on being part of that
and going back to the spot that's meant
so much to you and being part of
something that's so remarkable Jeff that
must be pretty yeah I went I went to
four colleges rich and I finally I was
like one of those perpetually like
finding myself type of guy sure so I I
found my home I went I was I don't know
about you but I did college in five
years
I don't know about you ready no we did
it before yeah yeah I did it for it but
see you were a journeyman is that what
you're saying you were a journeyman in
that going to school is what you're
saying Jeff what do they call that back
in the day with my age finding yourself
and my dad going into the fifth year it
said I hope you finally found yourself
because this is a last year you're on
the payroll in my house so that's too
bad if you're finding yourself you
didn't cross paths with wooden and
Walton then Jeff not to later in life
exactly hey Jeff thanks for the call
preciate always enjoy our chats we'll
chat throughout the season that and
enjoy that Bryan you got that Jeff Van
Gundy here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app